you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 24
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
some basic checkmate patterns this is
another video in this playlist that is
of the standalone type a non
prerequisite type video this will give
me an opportunity to share the names of
checkmate patterns with you but what's
more important than knowing the names is
knowing what that actually looks like on
board so that you can better recognize
these patterns in your own game and so
that you can see how the pieces interact
with one another I have exactly 17
examples to share with you in this video
covering a total of five checkmate
patterns namely the back ranked mate the
hook mate
Anastasia's mate the blind swine mate
funny name and lastly maybe the most
popular checkmate pattern in the game
smothered mate before I go any further
I'd like to point out that these
examples I'm sharing with you I am
pulling from the site Leach s org
forward slash practice if you would like
to maybe go through these examples on
your own first and then come back to see
what I have to say and how I'm
highlighting the board etc feel free to
do that I've included a link in the
description for you so with that said I
think we can simply go ahead and tackle
these seventeen examples first one is
the one we see here covering the back
ranked mate the white is on move and
after the move rook to e8 it is said
black just got back rank mated
notice all these squares would be taken
away and well that's the ballgame one
thing that we can also say about this
position is that black is lacking
a slight square this is a tournament
I've got to cover what is a flight
square in the game well if black had his
pawn on h6 we can say black has the h7
square as a flight square this is a
square the king can run too so that he
can avoid getting back rank made it not
the case here
rook e8 is mate have a look at another
example of back rank mate similar
pattern of pawns no-flight square 14
black black even white in this position
is vulnerable to getting back rank mated
if it was black to move rook takes rook
and it would be white who gets back rank
mated
why does I move however and there's a
couple ways you can approach this one
either Queen takes record rip takes rook
on move one will do the trick you can
take like this the computer will be
making the replies so if you're going
through these on your own first you may
see some different moves being played
but anyhow after rook takes rook here we
have another case of checkmate black is
now back rank mated this is the third
and final example of backlink mate so
this one turns out to be a checkmate in
three couple tempting options here to
maybe give a check like this but that is
not correct the best first move here is
Queens f7 so slightly different in this
example black does not have three pawns
walking his way but now that he's in the
corner you know he only needs these two
pawns on g7 and h7
to potentially be back rank mated the
follow-up move of sacrificing the Queen
will do the trick
rook takes Bishop and we have another
instance of back rank mate so those are
the only three covering back rank mate
we now move on to what's known as a hook
mate
this involves well at least on the
aggressors side white side in this case
point is on moon it involves a pond that
supports a knight and also a rook now
you'll notice the pond defends the night
and the night guards in the important
square on eh okay there's some nice
coordination going on after the move
rook to e8 all the squares are taken
away from the black King and that's
checkmate notice that there's also a
friendly pond on blacks end that plays
an important role for white really takes
away a square that the king can run to
this is a this is quite a popular
pattern in the game han defends the
night the night guards this d8 square
and yeah the rook sliding over to this
point will be checkmate notice the e8
square I like to identify as an
intersection square this will be a
common idea
throughout pieces playing to
intersection squares yeah they tend to
be good moves after rook to e8 that's
the ball game
let's see another example of hook mate
here a lot more pieces on board but
still a similar idea here similar
pattern going on notice we have a pawn
defending a night and this Knight is
guarding the g6 square so if we can
somehow get our rook here of course the
rook doesn't move like this but if we
can somehow manage to put the rook there
we're going to win and we could manage
that in just a few moves starting first
with rook g7 sacrificing a rook but now
black has to block on g6 and once we
take again once more we have
this pattern of pieces and this guy here
on h5 is getting in the King's way rook
takes rook is once more mate and now the
third and final example of Hooke mate
white is on move in the first two
examples we saw there there was a pawn
that was a little to the left of the
night okay he's on the right in this
case defending the knight but notice if
we could somehow get to this square here
the b8 square that will be another case
of mate and we can force through that
with a clean sacrifice after Queen takes
bishop if the King goes here Queen to d8
will be checkmate
what will happen after King takes clean
well notice we can bring the rook down
and actually before I even make that
move the King will have a couple options
but regardless of where he goes
you'll notice the rook can go to d8 or
even b8 and the knight is there
supporting both in both would be mate so
let's see where the computer chooses to
go to the King he went to b7 and our
last move here rook to b8 is checkmate
okay that's the last example of hook
mate moving on to now Anastasia's mate
this is a cool one involving a knight
and major piece in a way and Anastasia's
makes is not too far off from being like
a back ranked mate it's just kind of off
to the side like a checkmate along a
file you'll notice from this position
it's well first off it's white to move
the knight is guarding these two squares
g8 and g6 and this pawn on g7 is in the
King's way so he can't step up this in a
way it's like there's no flight square
for the King they're all taken away and
we need only to control these three from
this position in a major piece any major
piece on any of these three squares will
do the trick
in this case earth to h5 is mate here's
another example of Anastasia's mate for
examples total of Anastasia's mate
similar situation
notice the knight controlling these two
and we can go in first for a queen
sacrifice so we could see a little bit
of progression with these examples we
can take on h7 and after King takes
nine or to h5 and that will once more be
checkmate in our third example we first
pivot the night here
sacrifice and finally come over for this
checkmate move and the last example
working now is team black hopefully we
see the pattern here we see the idea
everything is kicking out for the night
guarding these two squares and we have
this one friendly pond that is well
really not so friendly for white in this
case that it gets in the King's way
after 92 we can now sacrifice the Queen
on h2 and give this I guess we could say
file checkmate this delivered if
Anastasia's make alright that is the
final example for Anastasia's mate
moving on to the second last one The
Blind swine mate I like to call these
guys pigs when they are on the seventh
rank there are hungry pieces there's
often a lot of enemy pawns back they can
be eating and in this position we have a
checkmate in string
vii hungry pieces they mop up these two
and notice that the rip on f8 is getting
in the King's way after this your place
here that is checkmate another example
of the blind swine mate first replay
with g7 and now we get a second rook on
the seventh rank and now there's just
computer like moves to delay the
eventual checkmate which involves once
more having the Brooks on these two
squares guarding all four there's not
much that black can do we can take the
knight
take the rook and eventually we're going
to be able to force through a similar
pattern
checkmate on board
one final example and white is on move
here we can capture on f7 and if rook
takes pawn we would play a check the
rook would have to return to f8 and we
would take the rook for checkmate let's
see what black does though see with
computer chooses to do gives a check ok
we take here this is allowing the night
to move and there would be a discovered
check so just to avoid all that we can
make a king move there's no fear of the
pond trying to score a touchdown because
all of whites moves are hitting with
check along the way and eventually
checkmate so let's just play King h3 get
out of any harm's way and okay the rook
makes a move we give a check and
hopefully we are seeing this little
pattern seeing how powerful two rooks on
the seventh can be okay that's going to
do it for blind swine mate we've come to
the last one
this is highlighting the smothered mate
involves a knight delivering the final
blow and what are some visual cues well
the enemy King his movement is
restricted greatly by his own pieces
there's no square that he can move to in
this position type Knight f7 and simply
checkmate have a look at number two
second of four examples for smothered
mate we can force through a checkmate
first capturing on h7 and once more
there's now no safe square for the King
Knight f7 is checkmate another variant
of this this is a pretty cool one
sacrificing the Queen on g8 this forces
rook takes Queen the bishop is guarding
g8 so after Queen to g8 the King cannot
take the Queen and once more we're
seeing the king really boxed in here
the knight plans that final blow for
mate and this is the final example of
smothered mate and maybe even though
this is a little bit more involved of a
pattern a little well let's say more
moves deep in this example this is maybe
more common than any of the first view
that I've shared with you the night
working in combination with clean
they're a very powerful attacking duo
let's see how white can deliver check
lay here this happens to be a checkmate
in six and the first key move here is
Knight to c5 he he fits well on any of
these squares these are key sixteen
squares a knight on c5 is very good this
is delivering a discovered check by the
Queen computers prolonging this mate for
as long as possible
blocking first with the clean we simply
take and let me just point out that
after we take here if the King goes to
this square Queen here notice this
intersection square on b7 the night and
queen focusing on that square that would
be mate King is not going to go there
King here clean there is mate
what do we do in this position well
first we give a check
black only has one move and now a follow
up double check Knight to d6 both Queen
and night will be striking at the king
from that position
once more if the King goes to d8 Queen
here will be mate after this move he's
going to be eight however and now we
have a queen sacrifice this is again
setting up a smothered mate queen now
sweeps in to c8 forcing rip takes Queen
and we once more get to land that final
blow with the night notice all these
squares are taken away by the black
pieces Knight to d7 and that's going to
do it that is number 17 that is the
smothered mate this last one here again
some basic checkmate patterns to go
through hopefully this was a little bit
helpful to you and maybe learned a
couple terms along the way feel free as
usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and
we'll be doing some more of these in a
future videos covering these checkmate
patterns so that's all for now as usual
I hope you got something out of it take
care bye
you